Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Next Car Game.
A game that promises realistic soft body physics.
And if you don't know what that means, well, I mean, just kinda watch!
Holy crap!
It's deformable bodies with actually interacting physical parts that break and smash in realistic ways.
It's totally awesome!
So, uh, holy crap!
I'm gonna play around for a little bit in this little playground they got here
and you guys can watch the mayhem, and enjoy!
Come here, come here! I want blood!
Oh, i barerly got any blood
You! you got, you know, ugh, ok allright, well allright then
Wooah, where did i go!?
I'm flyin! Au
Where am i going?